with everybody in the audience please
drop the tip of his tongue over his
teeth the spirit of the story please
that's right thank you
oh that's the idea thank you
and what do you find anything wrong
bridgework missing T that's what I
thought well that's what the story is
about about teeth about danny smith
teeth in particular and here's Danny
applying for an important job what do
these teeth have to do with it
well are they helping him or spoiling
his appearance and his chances and if
they are helping him how did they get
the way they are just look or watch or
the answer to that
will have to go back through the years
to the time Wes was two months old stop
thinking about teeth hair goatee to
think about and there still is much
doing on the dental front six months
later when Danny ruled over in the order
of their appearance
mother
father
and his grandmother completing the
family growth following on here to have
discovered something and it beat this is
Danny's first yes that's what it is
Danny's first - there it is all alone
the drains place within comes company
well Danny getting along here here he is
way past to his mother has planned to
the presentation listen Danny to the
dancing what's the matter you got a
toothache
he said that all children should be
taken to the dentist as soon as their
baby teeth cut through the gum what
could be wrong with Danny's keep at his
age
nothing well I still think you all see
you didn't you have some time tomorrow
why don't you come along and see what
doctor don't have to think I think it's
a silly idea that has better teeth than
I have more of them - yes they forget
the whole thing so they went to the net
how do you do how do you do dr. Jones
how do you do mr. Smith my wife does
insist on having Danny's teeth examined
although I don't see why that's
necessary I'm sure there's nothing wrong
with them
maybe not but sis we can't be absolutely
sure of that until we've given his seats
a careful examination it may even be
necessary to x-ray them x-ray that's
right they're doing a great deal with
x-ray these days in fact I just received
a bulletin from the American Dental
Association showing some of their recent
findings perhaps you'd be interested in
seeing some of them I'm sure we would
yes of course
it's really amazing the things they're
accomplishing these days these cavities
were so small that the I might have
missed him but they didn't escape the
x-ray yes but if they're so small they
can't be harmful to us
well it's cavity is neglected it always
develops into a large one treatment
becomes more unpleasant takes more time
and costs more money
I hear this tooth was filled as soon as
decay appears and this tooth was
neglected and the decayed spread if such
a condition is not corrected it will
result in the loss of the tooth after
all they are only baby
yes they're baby teeth but they're very
important nevertheless if they're
decayed they will interfere with the
child's ability to chew his food and may
have a bad effect on a general health
but that's only part of the story early
loss of the baby tooth may cause the
adult teeth to come in crooked well the
things of the baby teeth are important
after all as usual my wife was right
there is still another important reason
for coming here time the child's first
experience with the dentist would be a
pleasant one it means an examination
possibly an x-ray and a caning
consequently he won't mind coming for
periodic checkup
I'd like to know if Danny's teeth are
alright then let's get started and dr.
Jones makes friends with Danny
make him feel right at home child
psychology they call it nowadays
Danny is a tease he has complete
confidence in the doctor the examination
is all part of the fun and Danny enjoys
and his parents are relieved for as dr.
Jones predicted Danny's first visit to
the dentist to the pleasant walk it will
be remembered as good fun when the time
the next visit rolls around four months
from now Danny won't have to be coaxed
and the visit was an informative one for
Danny's parents they learned a great
many surprising things about teeth that
day for instance dr. Jones told the
Smiths they could walk along anywhere
and stop almost anybody and find that
they have decayed teeth yes anybody at
all this young woman for instance she is
unaware of her neglect but look the
x-ray reveals the filling which
represents previous decayed taken care
of but here is a new cavity that needs
immediate attention
for this enterprising young merchant
selling service with a smile a happy lad
was laughing merry eyes assuredly he had
rhythm and maybe a song in his heart
whoa with the day his teeth have decayed
observe the x-ray shows he has a large
cavity in the baby tooth that he will
soon lose and a new cavity on the biting
surface of a second tooth
baby teeth going out second teeth coming
in and decay in both yes sir coming out
and going the doctor told the Smiths of
such as this retired lawmaker wise
enough to make a nation's laws but not
wise enough to take care of his teeth
just roll your eyes over this x-ray
absent okay anything wrong is there any
decent wrong let's examine the case of
this in a hurry gentlemen at one time or
another almost everybody has decayed
teeth and what do most of them do well
let's see what he does he thinks it over
very carefully besides he's too busy to
take care of a little cavity it doesn't
hurt and after all what's a little
cavity months go by and the year goes by
and then what happened the little cavity
has become a big cavity and the little
pain is a big pain so suddenly he's not
too busy
he wouldn't bother with a cavity so
he'll have to bother with bridge work
and he didn't want to run up a little
bill so now it's a big bill after all
what's a little cavity getting back to
the Smiths
dr. Jones told them there are three ways
of brushing teeth this way inside the
sides or the floor washing method very
effective for washing floors this is
known as the circular or window washing
treatment also very effective for
washing windows
and here is the right way the upper
teeth are brushed with the downward
motion the lower teeth with an upward
motion and the chewing surfaces are
brushed by putting the brush into the
grooves and vibrating it backward and
Paul sounds complicated but anybody can
learn well here is Danny again 8 years
old today and having himself a time
celebrating the occasion
Danny's building himself up to a
terrific case of what ontology too vague
to you and a toothache by any name hurts
just as much as Danny is beginning to
find out teeth can take so much
punishment from sweets as we can see in
this picture of decay Guinea star first
tooth then slowly cutting through until
the tooth has become infected at the end
of one of the rooms yes Danny doesn't
feel so good he has a very low opinion
of candy at the moment it wasn't all the
Candy's fault as mrs. Smith realized he
hasn't followed through on Danny's teeth
she kept the appointments for several
years and then well like a lot of
mothers she forgot result trouble well
better late than never
but unfortunately
it is too late
too late to save the infected moment for
dr. Jones had to extract it to prevent
further complication
he told mrs. Smith how serious an
infected tooth can be he showed her how
decay begins and when neglected
penetrates the enamel and attacks the
inner part of the teeth
how if permitted to decay spreads and
spreads sometimes causing an abscess and
an abscess like this means going going
and mrs. Smith properly sorry resolved
though such neglect would occur again
all that 16 years ago one happened to
Danny
well our frantic cameraman brings us up
to today and here is den a healthy
confident young man at 24 here is his
mother a bit older a bit rare and it's
possible a bit prouder of death this is
an eventful day in the Smith household
and the gaze smiles and cheery banter of
mother and son are just make-believe to
conceal the anxiety each field where
Danny has an appointment downtown for a
new job that's going to mean a lot to
him it's the job he was applying for
when we first met him back at the talk
of the story
we asked you if his personal appearance
evasion is landing the job
what part his teeth plays and how
necessary wasn't to take good care of
that the answers seem pretty obvious in
the light of what we've seen
good-looking teeth and good looking
appearance go hand in hand if you have
any doubt about how strong healthy teeth
compliment a lovely face this picture is
about face
dirt this young lady lovely teeth help
make the lady in love I keep always help
we don't appreciate how essential they
are until we make comparisons and
speaking of comparisons let's make some
the gentleman answered the purpose very
well would you say there was competition
from robert taylor here or here or here
after all what's a little cavity and
here's the business appointment that
started us on thinking we sought to
prove that good sound teeth are a must
if we would be helped but they are a
must if we value our personal offense we
feel danny has proved the point of our
argument but what about keeping our
teeth that way
how does Danny handle that much let's
see
monks job long hours hard work and lost
in the immediate problems before him
Danny is forgetting forgetting that
important date he has with the dentist
on June 18th June 18th Danny that's
today for the dentist
no he doesn't remember
well we've got some bad news he doesn't
know it yet but one of his teeth is
beginning to decay the strange part of
it is Danny takes his teeth
for example heats good solid food very
little sweets but his teeth are decaying
anyway that's how teeth are there's no
way of stopping the decay stepped by
going to a dentist having it removed and
the tooth filled Danny brushed his teeth
every day and properly - that doesn't
stop the case his teeth and your teeth
need more than a bath they need a
dentist well as you guessed danny has
entirely forgotten his dental
appointments in his enthusiasm for the
new job he has fallen into the neglect
comment - so many of us he just doesn't
realize how he'll look if he loses that
- it does make a difference doesn't it
Danny is going to be just another man
who wouldn't bother with a little cavity
that is unless something happens unless
something warns him of the danger Wow
well Danny got his warning the cold
water did the trick but he's lucky it
happens before the decay had gone too
far remember the pause that made him
remember he forgot and before you and I
can say see your dentist regularly Danny
will be sitting in the dentist's chair
and the tooth has been saved it has a
filling but it has and Danny's had a
lesson he's going to remember to visit
the dentist three times a year he's
going to remember that a regular treat
decay and help guard against the loss of
teeth that's pretty much the story
ladies and gentlemen
the story of Danny Smith it might have
been the story of you or you or you of
the fellow next door the girl down the
block
it might well be the story of this young
man named his first visit to the death
and happily bringing our story
to the end